now more broadly there's a big debate
going on about the future of boris
johnson right now do you think he should
resign
yes yes
right and i mean douglas ross who's the
the head of the scottish conservatives i
mean he was one of the first people to
sort of come out and say so publicly i
mean if boris johnson clings on should
douglas ross be considering his position
look you know
i think you will find very few if any
people in the scottish parliament and
probably across scotland who think
anything other than that boris johnson
should resign um you know
he appears to have
been serially breaching covert
regulations but perhaps most importantly
for somebody in his position he has
apparently not been honest and truthful
about it in the accounts he's given to
the house of commons so these are really
serious
allegations leveled at the prime
minister look i'm a critic of boris
johnson
at the best of times
i don't think it's any secret that i
think the office of prime minister in
the interest of the country would be
enhanced by boris johnson's departure
but there are big big issues of trust
and integrity at stake now and that's
why i do think boris johnson should
resign um douglas ross i think was right
to call for his resignation if that
resignation doesn't happen then yeah i
think there are questions about how the
scottish conservatives can ever ask
anybody to vote for a party led by boris
johnson but perhaps if you can
encouraging him to come onto your
program these are questions that douglas
ross is probably a better position to
answer than i am absolutely i mean boris
johnson would be a big loss for you
though i mean he's been a great
recruiting sergeant for the snp
well look boris johnson uh
is opposed i think by many many people
across scotland i would guess and i
think opinion polls bear this out by the
majority of people in scotland but it's
not just about boris johnson the
individual it's about a conservative
party that enabled and facilitated
somebody like boris johnson becoming
prime minister in the first place it's
not as if these
you know character flaws that people are
are now seeing very clearly in boris
johnson weren't known about before so
yeah douglas ross has now called for his
resignation but douglas ross
enthusiastically supported boris johnson
in his uh attempts to become leader of
the conservative party and prime
minister and of course for scotland
frankly there's a bigger issue at stake
here that we have prime ministers and
governments at westminster that are
elected regardless of what people in
scotland think you know people in
scotland haven't voted majority or an
end anywhere close to that conservative
in my entire lifetime and yet for most
of my lifetime we've been governed by
tory governments there's a systemic
democratic deficit at the heart of how
scotland is governed which is one of the
many reasons as you know i support
scotland becoming an independent country
so that we can choose our own
governments rather than have governments
we don't want feisty upon us